joining me now congresswoman Anna
Paulina Luna Congressman I know you were
there at the capital when it was
lockedown and you were with your
newborn what what happened yes ma'am I
yes ma'am I was actually coming back
from a Diwali event over on the Senate
side and we were told by officers as we
were driving back that there was some um
protesting but so to get back into the
capital so we ultimately did I was going
to pick up my stuff and no sooner did we
actually get into my office than it went
basically on lock down we weren't able
to leave I had my young staffers with me
it was obviously not peaceful and the
irony in this Laura is that these people
were supposed to be protesting for peace
in Palestine yet you see what they're
doing obviously attacking people and
frankly uh rightfully so Capitol Police
did defend us but I mean it's it's crazy
that this is today's day and age and
that this is supposed to be
acceptable well Congressman I was
hearing from some of the protesters in
in their mouthpieces that were speaking
saying oh well they didn't mean to
breach the door they they weren't going
to go into the building can you I mean
who believes that I and they were they
were pushing up against the Poli what
were they trying to do
then no one believes that and in fact I
actually reposted because I was on
Twitter and Democrat socialists of
America DSA mind you we have lawmakers
that are part of this organization in
Congress they actually accepted
responsibility for this and basically
stated that it was law enforcement that
was attacking them which you can see
from the footage is an absolute lie what
we have in this country right now is a
massive problem as you had mentioned
earlier with marxists these
organizations using this movement in
order to really bully elected officials
into doing what they want and using
violence to do so it's what the color
revolutions are and it's something that
we as lawmakers have to push back
on and Congressman I I don't want anyone
to forget what Alexandria Casia Cortez
did she made a big show about how
horrified she was on January 6th
misogyny and the racism that is so
deeply rooted and animated um that
attack on the capital there's a lot of
sexualizing of that violence and um I
didn't think that I was just going to be
killed I thought other things were going
to happen to me as well you thought you
were going to be raped yeah yeah has
anyone heard from her today and her
party's headquarters no were under siege
last night after all under
siege yeah I mean there hasn't been any
issuing of statements from anyone who is
tied to Democrat socialist of America
and what I find really disturbing about
this whole thing Laura is that when
we're sitting there talking about the
fact that most members of Congress some
of which do sleep in their offices and
then you have this happening right down
the street you had a Democrat member of
Congress come out and say that he was
basic basically in fear for his safety
and then you see these organizations
attacking their own party you can see
that the fracturing within the Democrat
Party especially among those that are
embracing anti-Semitism is unfortunately
alive and
well now Congressman what if it was some
uh right-wing group that was in the same
way with the same body language with the
same Force pushing up against the police
at the DNC what do you think AOC would
have done
then I mean I think that it would be
more than just AOC I think that you
would have seen the do J label these
people as domestic terrorists and go
after them and frankly being a member of
House oversight I've gone to the DC
prison I've seen exactly what some of
these people are facing charges wise and
the fact that only one person was
arrested after multiple of our Capitol
Police were assaulted you saw frankly
the whole Capital had to go on lockdown
because of this behavior and then you
see an organization that's blatantly
marxists owning it saying that they were
busting people in from New York and that
their quote unquote comrades were there
basically engaging in violence I mean I
would urge the speaker of the house to
open up a special committee to see
exactly where this funding is coming
from for these organizations that are
ultimately trying to undermine not just
the United States but our constitutional
republic yeah well we we know that they
can track transactions pretty easily on
ATM machines when they want to but
they're never going to track those
people congresswoman great to see you
I'm GL glad you're okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else